(upbeat live band music)
- Wow.
(audience cheers)
Wow, goodness!
- You are so...
Don't they look handsome?
- You guys.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Matt] You guys look incredible.
- [Kelly] I know.
Do you have family in the military?
- I do, my whole family is Navy.
Everybody from my uncle to my grandfather.
My great-grandfather was a
paratrooper in World War II.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- Which is insane to me.
'Cause if you've ever
been skydiving, you know-
- No, I haven't, won't.
- Well if you have any
level of depression at all,
I wouldn't recommend.
(Al Roker's partner laughs)
(audience laughs)
- So were you always funny as a kid?
- [Matt] Oh yes, I-
- You (indistinct) comedy?
- I was in constant detention-
(Kelly laughs)
And my mom-
- Your parents.
- My mom would whoop me for
days for getting detention.
And now that same skill
that got me detention
just bought her a house.
- There you go, there you go!
(audience cheers)
(audience claps)
- Now mine was talking too much.
- [Matt] Really?
- Who would've thought, yes.
- [Matt] Who would've guessed?
- Yes, and now I'm making
money off of it, whatever.
(Al Roker laughs)
So, did you know what you wanted to be?
Did you have an idea of
what you wanted to do
when you were younger?
- I had no idea; I was
gonna be in television.
I wasn't gonna work on TV.
I wanted to work in.
In fact, in my freshman year of college,
when I took a television
performance class,
my department chairman told me, Roker,
you have a perfect face for radio.
- Oh my God!
(people laugh)
- Oh my God, well you
can't hear that enough.
Whatever!
But you do have a great voice, actually.
- Well, thanks.
- That's-
- I've never been crazy
about my voice, but-
- Oh my gosh!
- Please do (indistinct)-
- I sound like a valley girl.
You sound like (indistinct),
it's got the low end,
like, uh!
- You can lull me to sleep, for sure.
In the best way.
- Well, I was gonna say-
- In the best way possible.
- I dunno if that's a comp.
- No, it's a 100%-
- It is a compliment,
It is a compliment.
- And here's the five-day forecast.
(Matt and Kelly laugh)
- So wait, over 17 million followers,
that's a little,
it's intimidating and kind
of overwhelming, right?
- A tad bit.
It does feel like it came out of nowhere.
But then I have to remind myself
as much as it feels overnight,
because it did happen very fast.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Via social media.
I'd been doing comedy
for 12 years before that.
- Yeah.
- So anytime I feel overwhelmed
about people coming up on
the streets or at restaurants
or something like that,
and they ask me, "Oh, I'm
so sorry to bother you."
I'm like, no, you're not a bother at all.
For 11 years I begged somebody to take-
(Al Roker laughs)
You kidding me?
- Notice me.
- Yeah, you know what's worse
than everybody knowing you.
Nobody knowing you.
- Yeah.
(Al Roker's partner laughs)
- It's amazing, this is the
first special for Netflix.
And I couldn't be more excited;
because I think, again,
it's just gonna broaden me
to a different audience,
that either sees me as
just a TikTok comedian
or someone who just does crowd work.
I think they're gonna
be pleasantly surprised
at what else I can do.
- Oh, I love that.
And I love that, when
people underestimate you,
'cause then it's like fun
and it fuels you.
- [Matt] Oh, of course.
- And you wanna win them over.
- Oh yeah, that's the
best revenge, success.
- The underdog is always a
better position in my opinion.
- [Matt] Oh, of course.
- Speaking of his fans, though,
this happened recently
at one of Matt's shows.
Watch this.
- [Patron] And she has wanted you
to figure out how to-
- [Matt] Oh, (bleep).
- [Patron] Original (indistinct).
- Yo, can we get a paramedic real quick?
Paramedic, please?
You okay?
- [Attendee] Oh, she's gonna cry in here.
- [Matt] You all right?
(attendee laughs)
You feeling okay, you promise?
- [Attendee] Can she
get a picture with you?
- Yeah (giggles), of course.
Just don't use it for
the obituary, my God.
(people laugh)
(people clap)
- That's the best line.
(audience cheers)
What happened?
(audience claps)
- Well she's okay.
She's fine.
- Which is why the joke is funny.
- Yeah, oh, of course, of course.
No, we wouldn't have continued the show
if someone (bleep) happens.
Like, somebody get her outta
here, I gotta plug merch.
(Kelly laughs)
No, no, I, no,
this looks-
(audience laughs)
(Al Roker claps loudly)
Cut!
Cut, rewind it.
- That's amazing!
That's amazing.
- This was probably 25 minutes
into one of our headlining shows.
And I hear this commotion and I look down
and I could see she's convulsing.
So I immediately, once I
recognized what was happening,
I called for anybody being
a paramedic in the room.
And luckily the people in the venue
and people who do work
in the medical field,
that were in the audience,
rushed to her side immediately.
I have to leave the
stage when that happens,
so that I can be informed
as to what's going on.
While she's getting tended to properly-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And not in anybody's way.
And it was like seven
or eight minutes later,
I would say, my security came back
and was like, "Hey,
she, she wants to stay."
(people chuckle)
I was like, I'll give her a refund.
Like she doesn't have to stay.
But she, I went out there, I was like,
lemme just go talk to her,
make sure she's all right.
And I walked out and the
first thing I said was like,
are you okay?
She was like, "Yeah,
can I have a picture?"
I was like, yeah, no flash.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
She had epilepsy.
What a wild thing to ask first, man.
But you go, you gotta, you
gotta respect the passion.
She wanted to stay.
She had carpe diem.
- Comedy makes people happy.
You make people happy-
- [Matt] Of course.
- You make people laugh.
I forgot this and I went to a
show here recently in New York
and it made me feel so good
to get out and just laugh.
- [Al] With other people.
- Yes.
- Oh, absolutely.
You have no idea.
It brings people together
to such an extreme level.
You'd think it's just-
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Random jokes that you're just telling
to make people happy.
- [Kelly] No we're all connecting-
- You have no idea what
people are going through.
- [Kelly] In a different way.
- Yes, absolutely.
She was such a good
sport about everything.
- It's actually happened
at a show for like,
it shows for me like you're
in live situations too.
Where things have happened like that
and you get, you freaked out.
'Cause you're like, well
wait 'cause loud music.
I'm like, make it go away.
- It's just stop.
Please stop.
- Yeah.
- Oh these kind of things
happen all the time.
We had an overdose in Indianapolis-
- Ooh!
- Like two weeks ago.
And the audience was furious
that he did not offer
to share with the rest of the crowd.
(people shout)
They were so mad.
- Whoa!
- I had no idea
Indianapolis was so ratchet.
Like they were so upset.
- [Kelly] But I (indistinct)!
- Like, usually people
rally behind something.
They're like, "Yeah,
make sure he is okay."
And they were like, "Selfish."
- Selfish!
Oh my God, you're so funny (laughs)!
- [Matt] I know, it was so ridiculous.
- Matt Rife everybody.
(crowd shouts)
"Natural Selection", on
Netflix, starting November 15th.
You gotta check it out!
(audience claps)